Now, I get slightly more complicated
in the case where there can be
only one policy.
And that's because for the very reason
that we described in the first quiz,
where if I know with certainty,
there's only one policy, and
I know with certainty, the human gives
me the right answer, the moment you tell
me that some action is correct, I now
know something about the other actions.
So it becomes complicated.
Somehow, what you've told me about
a second action tells me something about
the first action.
And when you go through all the math,
it's still a multinomial.
And when you go through all the math and
do the derivation, and
the derivation's available for the
students, you end up with this quantity.
That the probability that a particular
action A is optimal given a sequence
of labels is what we've seen before,
it's c raised to the delta sub
a (1-c) raised to all the other evidence
that we have from the other actions.
And then there's a normalization
factor which I don't write out here.
And this corresponds to what
we did in the last example,
where we wrote out 0.8, 0.2, and
0.2 and then normalized everything out.
>> And
let me make sure I understand that.
So we have 1.2, the delta is 1.
>> Yes.
>> No, but it's 0 for the other guys?
What's delta j?
Delta j is for the other actions.
>> Yes, this is the difference between
the times you said yes and no for
every other action that isn't the
particular action you're asking about.
So this provides evidence
from the other actions.
>> I see, and
then we're going to normalize.
So maybe that squiggle equals
wants to be like an alpha,
like a proportional to symbol?
>> Yeah, sure, I usually write squiggle,
where I grew up in the South,
that meant approximately.
But there, that make you feel better?
>> Much better, because it's not
really approximately, it's actually
proportional to, which means we're
going to have to normalize afterwards,
so that we get the 0.8,
we get a 0.2 and a 0.2.
And then when we normalize it,
we get the 2/3, 1/6, 1/6.
Awesome.
>> Exactly.
And the right thing
kind of happens there.
And you could write out what
the normalization factor is, and
then we don't have to have an alpha
here, we can have an equals.
But it's big, long, and hairy, and it's
just much simpler to actually ignore it,
do this part, which is really easy.
And then do the normalization
afterwards.
More to the point,
since what we care about is a policy,
we only care about which one's maximal.
We don't actually care about
the actual probability.
>> I'm forgetting why
we care about a policy.
>> Remember.
>> because we're trying to,
because ultimately,
we're combining this information
to figure out what action to take.
>> Right.
>> Got it.
>> If all we're doing is listening to
human beings, then when a human tells
us something, we want to pick the action
that's most likely to be optimal.
And so it doesn't matter what
the actual probability is so
long as we have the ordering right.
And so we don't have to normalise.
We don't have to know the probability,
we just have to make certain
we get the maximum one right.